[Musique]
il a été contrebandi en Afrique
organisateur de jeu clandestin au Canada
et chercheur d'or au Costa Rica voici
l'histoire de l'aventurier écrivain
Sydia il est égoïste jouisseur brutal
cynique misogyne épouvantable
émerveilleux voilà c'était un homme
extraordinaire
des mesuré en tout mais vous êtes
terrible non
nous sommes en 1985 sydiazé est invité
sur le plateau d'apostrophe une émission
littéraire très populaire présentée par
Bernard Pivot les Français découvrent
alors un écrivain atypique venu
bousculer la bienséance de l'émission
comme ça les gens c'est bien comme
celui-là
aussi étonnant aussi délicat
euro livre autobiographique raconte les
aventures de zik et Costa Rica où il
s'est accaparé une mine d'or est-ce que
vous avez déjà tué déjà on ne pose pas
ce genre de question
il cherchait quelqu'un l'assistant pour
bosser avec lui et il m'a donné
rendez-vous dans un PMU près du près du
Luxembourg à Paris je lui avais apporté
quelques petites nouvelles que j'avais à
l'époque je publiais beaucoup dans des
forgines punk la feuilletée il m'a dit
c'est toi quels sont les origines de
votre prénom de votre nom à l'année
c'est albanais par exemple l'histoire de
commence en 1949 à Taroudant dans le sud
du Maroc les gens-charles sa mère est
grecque et son père est dans la Légion
étrangère lors de l'indépendance du
Maroc en 1956 sa famille s'installe à
Bordeaux adolescent turbulence ziqué
fait son premier séjour en prison à 18
ans quand il était la main c'était un
escroc sans pitié puis allez vous
chercher l'argent dans dans les poches
il s'engage ensuite dans la Légion
étrangère mais se fait renvoyer au bout
de quelques semaines ziker décide de
partir à l'aventure il s'envole pour
l'Argentine où il devient propriétaire
de boîte de nuit avant d'atterrir au
Canada où il devient chasseur de dettes
et organisateur de jeu clandestins a
toujours vécu autour du monde il avait
été contrebandier dans le désert escroc
en Amérique latine trafiquant de sites
trafiquants de ça avec sa compagne il
perd un enfant en bas âge le couple
transit par Hong Kong et Macao avant
d'échoué au Costa Rica au début des
années 80 la mort en bas âge
de son fils qui n'avait même pas un an
avec les un drame terrible pour lui il
s'est enfoncé dans la jungle pour pour
cesser de penser à cette douleur la
fièvre de l'or à chasser cette mauvaise
pensée existe et ça c'est très possible
dans un campement et autre chose des
gens qui sont portés qui veulent qui
sont capables
qu'ils font quoi qu'il tue pour voler
lors du copain alors qu'il s'enfonce
dans la jungle Costa ricienne ziquer
fait la rencontre de trafiquants et
d'orpailleurs clandestin pour assurer sa
sécurité il s’équipe d'une arme
imposante le 357 Magnum là où les gens
sont armés on s'arme
tout le monde est en armé il faut avoir
le flingue le plus impressionnant voilà
tout simplement Costa Rica dans une zone
où il y a pas mal de bandits et les gens
sont tarés c'est l'explication possible
son taré là-bas
il faut se défendre parce que les gens
tirent dans le dos après quelques
tentatives peu fructueuses sur la
péninsuledosa ziqué finit par décrocher
le Graal il découvre une mine d'or alors
là c'est un filon formidable parce que
ça va vous rapporter combien de kilos
d'heures la 3 kilos à la main 23 kg à la
main il s'est construit un code moral on
s'attaque pas certaines personnes on
s'attaque pas aux gens vulnérables on
est je crois qu'un escroc esprit la
vieille la vieille dame se trouve facile
vous avez combien d'esclaves qui
travaillent pour vous une trentaine une
trentaine et vous ne protestez pas quand
je dis le mot esclave premièrement il
faut habituer habituer les gens de
travailler
c'est ma mine d'or il faut pas qu'il
pense à voler la première tension est de
venir pour voler ce qui est normal je
comprends
je le comprends mais je n'accepte pas
donc il faut donc
les tuer au travail
tout ce qui est dans le livre c'est vrai
non seulement c'est vrai mais en plus il
en manque quoi
Bernard Pivot a lu à l'antenne une
lettre de l'ambassadeur du Costa Rica il
s'étonne beaucoup que dans une émission
aussi raffinée qu'apostrophe on puisse
inviter des gens comme vous dans de
nombreux paragraphes l'auteur insulte
hommes et femmes et donne une image
erronée de la vie nationale la portée du
préjudice que cette oeuvre pourra causer
à mon pays est un comment mensurable le
fait que Bernard Pivot lise cette lettre
ça authentifié toute l'aventure dès le
lendemain les ventes c'était c'était
phénoménal alors qu'on était des demi
clochards on est devenu des sortes de
Rockstar du jour au lendemain après
avoir fait fortune avec sa mine d'or zik
et doit fuir le Costa Rica sous la
pression des autorités et se réfugier au
Panama
j'étais associé avec une déjà très
importante dans le pays qui contrôle le
pays et ils m'ont volé la mine quoi
et comme après chaque aventure il
dilapide son butin le jeu ouais le jeu
la flammeuse
[Musique]
et nous on était merde
parce que le soir au lieu de la côte de
bœuf et vin rouge c'était bol de riz
berdo quoi j'ai voulu aurez confié vos
économies
on a l'impression même que pour repartir
dans une nouvelle aventure il faut que
vous n'ayez plus rien c'est nécessaire
un homme d'affaires veut s'enrichir un
bandit
s'enrichir l'aventurier non entouré
l'aventure c'est forcément un échec il
faut terminer comme Lucky Luke pour
London cowboy
en ayant tout perdu le passage à Paris
quelques temps après son retour
d'Amérique latine c'est par hasard que
ziqué entame sa nouvelle vie d'écrivain
il a dîner avec un journaliste il a
raconté son histoire de mine d'or et le
gaz il faut faire un livre monsieur vous
vous rendez pas compte c'est
extraordinaire et là liquide s'est rendu
compte que ça plaisait beaucoup à sa
mère pour sa mère comment dire
écrivain à succès c'est mieux que bandit
international
qui est fausse
il faut être dur toute l'oeuvre est
fortement imprégné de cannabis plus tout
ce qui pouvait traîner pour faire la
fête mais l'écriture le cannabis
et puis après il y a
sinon je prends des hallucinogènes si tu
veux
faire
après une aventure après quelques années
passées en Albanie le pays d'origine de
son père ziquet reprend ses activités
d'orpailleurs en Guyane cette fois son
projet créé un casino flottant dans la
jungle surinamienne il est finalement
arrêté et mis en examen pour complicité
d'orpaillage clandestin
[Musique]
liquide est a vraiment un auteur
populaire dans tous les sens du terme je
pense qu'auro a mis des milliers des
milliers de jeunes gens dans les avions
ils ont eu ça ils ont dit bon ben il
faut que j'aille voir il faut que
j'aille découvrir le monde c'est pas
possible en 2011 zik et meurt d'une
crise cardiaque à Bordeaux la ville de
son enfance
le dernier coup de fil c'était la ville
de Samo pour la première fois
pencher sur son passé il m'a dit c'est
marrant je pense jamais au passé et puis
là j'ai réfléchi quand même j'ai une
belle vie
et il m'a dit je
kiffe chaque instant
et c'est le dernier mot en fait comment
dire le plus grand ami qui m'est explosé
de rencontrer quoi
pour moi posséder et négatif et je suis
fier à mon âge de ne rien posséder rien
faire